[Música]
le damos en su programa canadá en las
américas café que hoy podríamos llamar
canadá en la navidad o el castor cyber
navideño les damos la bienvenida aquí a
nuestros estudios en montreal los saluda
paloma martínez saludamos también a
todos aquellos que nos están siguiendo
por internet ya sea por youtube por
facebook live o por nuestro sitio
internet directamente ahí estamos viendo
imágenes de navidad en todo canadá en
todas las regiones de canadá así que
estamos iniciando este programa que es
navideño porque es el último del año es
el programa que es antes de navidad
entonces aquí estamos todos muy bien
preparados si quieren podemos mostrar
exagerando un poco luis laborda
muy bien muchas gracias leonardo gimeno
[Aplausos]
tenemos un invitado especial alguien que
nuestros oyentes no conocen aún o
aquellos que siguen en francés o en
inglés lo deben haber visto ya pero es
más chula ser que nos acompaña aquí en
el estudio matthew cómo estás muy bien
muchas gracias y tú estoy muy bien
gracias por acompañarnos y de hecho las
imágenes que estábamos viendo es un
momentito son imágenes que matthew
preparó presentó es un diaporama sonoro
que la gente va a poder ver también en
nuestro sitio internet a partir de la
próxima semana pero que en un momento
vamos a conversar con más yo al respecto
y lo vamos a volver a ver este día
programa así que bienvenido más llegar a
instalar yo antes de hablar de navidades
de otros temas así quería hablar de ese
bonete justamente de ese foro
que pablo tiene muy bien pues lo que lo
luce muy bien y además
si no lo tenemos acá después d
no no no
no tenemos alguien muy especial a quien
agradecer por ese gorrito
es la esposa de leonardo que anoche
estuvo haciendo este gorrito para que
pablo tuvieran que ponerse la cabeza
con este adorno delante ustedes solo y
también anabel ya hizo esto que está
llevando a que tiene leonardo en su
cuerpo
el su atlético cuerpo gran abel ya
tratar bien este es este suéter como le
llamen ustedes a los suéteres
suerte que tiene es el tienes el
micrófono enfrente del suéter entonces
no lo ponga estar entonces es papá noel
con sus lentes no para los lados eso sí
muy bien lo hizo bordado prácticamente
cocidito guardadito cortas
[Risas]
y luis no se quiso poner aquí el olvido
adornar ahora tengo un chaleco que
podría haber traído que es típicamente
una vida de mi vida para los espíritus
festivos que festejamos los 365 días del
año un día más y yo me puse este suéter
que tiene hay para dónde voy acá que
tiene la forma de unas galletitas de
jengibre que son típicas de navidad en
las casas de jengibre y la galletita
estos muñequitos
exactamente así bueno hablemos más de
jengibre más
bueno de jengibre
de hecho por una compañera de trabajo de
anabela de mi esposa africana era una
delicia y aparte
el jengibre
y tenía un jugo que hizo con jengibre
conoce que otras esencias de especias
que eras decía super floreciendo
bueno vamos hablar de jengibre en un
momento más porque palo tiene una
sorpresa navideña relacionada con el
jengibre ya van a ver pero antes
volvamos al día programa sonoro que
preparo matthew para está justamente
para ilustrar bien cómo los canadienses
celebran la navidad en las calles
entonces lo podemos ver de nuevo el día
programa mientras nos cuenta es matthew
cómo fue el proceso de hecho de dónde
viene la idea de hacer este día programa
de navidad de canadá que es hace parte
de escenas de vida que es una
colaboración con 5 radios
internacionales como una radio rumanía
internacional
swissinfo en suesa y radio praga
internacional y radio polonia
internacional
las tres primeras tienen también sus
sitios en español así que quieres verlo
puedes ir y hemos hecho muchos sujetos
con ellos como historias de radios
internacionales estadios de fútbol
aeropuertos y de mercados estaciones de
tren iglesias y ahora hacemos
así hemos tenido la idea que canadá es
enorme y vemos todas las imágenes de
todo canadá normalmente hacemos cosas de
montreal y hemos dicho tenemos que hacer
cosas más de todo canadá así que hemos
pedido los otros periodistas estaciones
de radio de radio canadá adentro de
décadas de mandarnos fotos así que nos
han mandado demasiados fotos tuvo que
hacer una selección
no estábamos viendo el producto haciendo
el producto me va mostrando mira la vida
cuatro minutos y medio minutos de sacar
fotos
y también lo importante es que es un
diaporama sonoro como y inmersivo así
que el sonido no es música es como si tú
estabas
así que vas a ver y tienes los marketers
de navidad y todo eso
[Música]
en español publicados así que puede que
ya sepan que el martes y el miércoles
tienen que ir en nuestro sitio para
escuchar el sonido del día podemos
pero aquí en el programa queríamos
justamente tener las imágenes para que
la gente tenga una idea de cómo estamos
celebrando navidad y es que los días
están cerquita así que muy bien ha sido
muy buen trabajo mucho trabajo y ahí
tenemos las y me imagino los nombres
también las personas que colaboraron
contigo para realizar para el envío de
las fotos desde todas las regiones
canadienses pero si si quieres saber de
vida en canadá tienes que saber que en
canadá hay tres cosas muy importantes
para navidad que hay al árbol de la vida
que es muy importante en canadá y lo
tienes adentro de casas y también en
ciudades
por todas parte y también tienes las
decoraciones navideñas navideña eso y
las luz lo has visto en el vídeo sobre
el pavimento de ottawa hacen un
espectáculo de luz durante todo el mes
de diciembre es maravilloso al ver no lo
he visto yo he visto las fotos y los
vídeos pero están muy bien y también
tienen los marketers de navidad mercados
mexicanos
y es interesante porque en canadá es una
mezcla de las tradiciones
ingleses americanos y franceses así que
de este han creído creado una nueva
tradición canadiense con todo lo que he
dicho el árbol lo las iluminaciones y
así que en 2018 estaba la primera
destinación para celebrar navidad del
mundo
2018 lo hicieron 30 bajo cero hace tres
semanas
bueno se está acercando a la navidad y
ayer cuando hizo de temperatura yo le
envié una imagen de la pantalla de mi
móvil a varios amigos en argentina
porque cuando cuento las temperaturas
que hacen aquí
y sobre todo la sensación térmica dicen
han exageres tampoco la paga y ayer
demande estaba haciendo a las seis y
veinte de la mañana cuando estaba
viniendo hacia aquí 19 grados bajo cero
de temperatura y 31 de sensaciones
ajá
y creo que bajó un poquito más
4 calor brutal para la semana que viene
2 grados
estaba más frío por el norte
-29 y aquí menos 33 es una de las cosas
que yo público
en las redes sociales cuando sucede que
es seguido porque montreal es una de las
urbes pobladas más frías del mundo hace
más frío que en siberia hace más frío
que en cualquier ciudad inclusive el año
pasado en esas tres semanas del mes de
diciembre que es un frío extraordinario
durante una semana estuvo más frío que
en la antártida del polo norte en
siberia
y benicarló with creo que era la otra de
la otra referencia que es una ciudad
bien en el norte es brutal el frío ha
pasado lo hemos dicho varias veces si
usted vive o vivió en canadá puede vivir
en cualquier cosa cualquier estepa por
ahí pérdidas e injustamente para
regresar a lo de iqaluit ayer la hacía
dos bajo cero creo en iqaluit mientras
que aquí estábamos con la sensación
térmica 39-31 más bueno entonces pero si
preocuparme porque eso probablemente
tiene que ver con los cambios climáticos
en iqaluit porque debería ser más frío
ahora pero me preocupa eso sino bueno
entonces estamos celebrando navidades
con estas imágenes que machi nos va a
presentar a partir de la próxima semana
en todos los sitios en todas las lenguas
de radio canadá internacional en la
sección de escenas de la vida cierto a
partir del martes y el miércoles próximo
iniciando las y como decía más yo pueden
ir a ver también las otras y en realidad
y una página general donde están
presentadas
lo que ya hemos hecho y se va a poner en
primera plana el que viene de realizar y
también en suiza y en república checa y
en polonia en rumanía así que nos han
mandado sus vídeos también y así que
para saber cómo es en cada iba a saber
cómo es en europa dentro de sus ciencias
sus propias vacaciones
pero no es porque es el último programa
de este año
porque no me quedó claro mientras se me
preguntaba si le había quedado claro a
nuestro oyente este programa es nuestro
último programa del año volvemos a
canadá en las américas café el 10 de
enero entonces por eso estamos
celebrando la navidad y el fin de año y
todo al mismo tiempo porque así le había
quedado claro a nuestros oyentes y
entonces el próximo viernes cuando
llegue entonces va a provocar una crisis
empezamos con miriam alarcón of fun que
nos dice hola como estan se los ve muy
bien y listos para festejar siempre
estamos de festejos mínimos
gustavo lucas también top fun dice va a
estar desde la ciudad de melo
departamento de cerro largo uruguay
saludos a matthew y quien ya he visto en
los programas en francés con stefan dice
navidad para todos los que hacen el
programa y sobre todo para los oyentes
así que muchas gracias gustavo
este saludo y por participar siempre con
nosotros los días bien
la verás un poquito de ruido
si se escucha dijo chantal que no tenías
que mover el micrófono dijo
bueno pablo sigamos festejando con el
casita la casita más chiquitita del
mundo si espera nadien se hizo de ésta
está hecha con ese mismo material del
que te estabas hablando desde las
galletitas se suele decíamos que se
suele aquí en canadá hacer para esta
época navideña navideña casas en pan de
jengibre y bueno pues eso efe hecho de
la misma forma con el mismo método es la
casita más pequeña y esa casa mide 10
micrones de largo por 6 micrones de
ancho
ahora para que quede claro y eso lo
interesante que
es un micrón un micrón es el equivalente
de la milésima parte de un milímetro
entonces quiere decir que es más pequeño
que la punta de una aguja o de la punta
de un alfiler en realidad mucho material
no utilizó entonces mucho jengibre no
necesito pero le había lo interesante y
no sé si lo vieron en las fotos es que
en la casa está construida en la cabeza
de un muñeco de nieve sí sí sí y al lado
es una foto general en el otro vídeo
porque esa es la cómo fue fabricada y
vemos las etapas por las que se pasó
pero un poquito más abajo hay otro otro
vídeo donde en el reporte en el
reportaje se tendrán que ir entonces se
ve una foto del conjunto quiero decir de
el muñeco de nieve
con la casita encima de la cabeza el
muñeco de nieve haciendo un guiño de un
ojo y al lado hay como que hay un
cabello entonces para que se le dé para
que tengan una idea proponente de la
proporción ese cabello es como si fuera
el tronco de un árbol inmenso al lado de
lo que está lo que se está mostrando y
quién hizo esta casita este es el centro
de bueno el instigador del proyecto se
llama travis casa grande
algo es español y él es trabaja en el
centro canadiense de microscopía
electrónica entonces la idea de hacer
esto y este señor ha hecho otras y tiene
otros proyectos de fabricación de
cositas más pequeñas entre otras una
bandera canadiense
el borde de un centavo hizo un hueco en
el borde del centavo y al interior de
ese borde ahí adentro entonces puso una
banderita canadiense y eso lo había
hecho para festejar el canal el día de
canadá
así es que entonces y la idea detrás de
todo esto y de esta de estas
curiosidades tan pequeñitas es demostrar
una parte una parte la tecnología de la
que disponen que es la universidad van a
tener y de la utilización que se hace de
esa tecnología en todo lo que respecta a
la
[Música]
la fabricación de herramientas y
fabricación de materiales para la
industria canadiense y del mundo que
también tiene debe tener algunas
utilizaciones en los en la medicina de
la nanotecnología en forma estamos
hablando de nanotecnología porque lograr
hacer esta es la parte digamos
artísticas
pero tiene otras aplicaciones que bueno
se van a ver con el correr del tiempo se
están viendo ya insular en todo es parte
de un canal hay en distintos lugares del
mundo muchas gracias
[Risas]
anabella dice que está con una amiga
dispar vara dice feliz janucá también si
nunca pensamos en ello pero es verdad la
pija nuca aunque ellos no
reparten regalitos voy a dejar claro yo
vamos a la inversa vamos a celebrar
janucá así podamos repetirse pues muchas
gracias saludos a ambas entonces un
abrazo y gracias de nuevo por el gorrito
y tenemos también por ahí una foto de
alguien de tu familia si como ustedes
saben en todas las familias bueno la
mayoría de las familias estas fiestas
siempre mueven sentimientos de todo tipo
que se alejan más y quien celebran menos
y este personaje que ustedes ven ahí
como buen golden retriever toda fiesta
le viene bien cualquier cosa le vienen
para festejar y aprovechó entonces la
navidad para lucir el tocado navideño
que
se cree este señor se llama tango
a los 13 años pero bueno mayor es
precioso es mayor si es talla mayor pero
a pesar que está mayor en cuanto a la
cantidad de años el espíritu de cinta y
fiestas dicen que los golden retriever
se vuelven más apacibles a partir de los
3 o 4 años este nunca se enteró
y leonardo toda esta semana como siempre
ustedes efemérides importantes muy
interesantes pero son todos locales la
mayoría locales entonces la que sacamos
fue la internacional y hoy justamente es
el día internacional de la solidaridad
humana
exacto exacto y sobre todo porque bueno
la época de fiestas uno intenta dar un
poco más y están las no sé cómo se
traduce la quiniela de fondos y de
alimentos para la gente que más necesita
bueno justamente a partir del 2005 la
onu dispuso este día como el día
internacional de la solidaridad humana y
dentro del término de solidaridad en
genes solidaridad en general dice bueno
porque se celebra la unidad en la
diversidad la sensibilización por la
gente solidaria y para sensibilizar a la
gente también a ser solidarios el
desarrollo sostenible y erradicar la
pobreza como base de este día
en erradicar la pobreza que es una tarea
que es difícil muy difícil y bueno pero
ponen las intenciones están ahí y yo
creo que la gente en general se implica
mucho en esto creo que radio canadá
recaudó muchísimo dinero una radio
canadá pero los medios canadienses
recaudaron mucho dinero en las semanas
pasadas en este niño leo en esta
recaudación de fondos para navidad que
se llevan los diferentes organismos
posteriormente que trabajan con gentes
en todos los sectores de la luz y en
realidad participe una discusión con
amigos que hablando justamente de la
solidaridad y la capacidad que tiene el
canadiense de dar y la discusión era
porque ellos decían queda que nada era
más que en otros países yo creo que en
américa latina también se da se da de
otra manera se da de otra manera porque
se da a los medios década claro exacto y
el hecho de que acá está muy bien armado
estructurado con los medios de
comunicación entonces lo vemos en la
televisión lo vemos en la escuchamos la
edad
eso se ve y no tanto en nuestros países
pero creo que la solidaridad es una base
facenda no se ve hoy en día porque hay
que reparar nuestros países han pasado
por una serie de crisis económicas que
afectan el bolsillo de la gente pero
cuando yo era pequeño no hace tanto
tiempo la gente americanas es nada y
mucho donaba y muchísimo no solamente
para las fiestas sino para distintos
eventos durante el año después de las
crisis financieras que han afectado los
distintos países es un poco más difícil
meter la mano en el bolsillo pero como
bien vos decías hay otro tipo de
solidaridad solidaridad que siempre está
presente en la periferia y creo que en
méxico por ejemplo se organiza lo que
llama los teletones tienes y ahí están
organizadas los medios de comunicación y
recaudan fondos y además van a buscar
dinero también de ciertas instituciones
privadas yo entonces incluyen a la
sociedad civil pero también a los a la
gente que tiene más dinero en las
compañías rosas y recaudan fondos de esa
manera en méxico por lo menos existe ese
proyecto y con respecto a la solidaridad
del pueblo argentino
quiero agregar de que eso no es nuevo
mira yo estuve en argentina en 1972 yo
sí
y bueno este día 20 años cuando llegue a
activo entonces quería decir de qué y
creo que no ha cambiado me corrigen si
me equivoco la educación en argentina
una de las razones por la cual había
tantos estudiantes extranjeros en
argentina era porque la educación
universitaria era gratuita es y sigue
siendo entonces a mí me parece que si
eso no es solidaridad como lo podríamos
llamar osea yo tengo lo y lo digo
siempre alto y lo repito que argentina
educo a una buena parte de la élite y de
profesionales de sudamérica
hablamos de sólidas youtube de gente de
amigos quiere estudiar medicina y tenían
compañera de toda latinoamérica y no era
porque era un aparato no era porque era
más barato mandarlos argentinas sino
porque sí
profesional recibido en argentina en las
carreras que tienen que ver con la
medicina tiene prestigio súper
importante
que son las anécdotas de pablo por las
calles de buenos aires
la serie y relacionadas con argentino
justamente
recientemente tuve algunos problemas
cardíacos me tuvieron que poner un
marcapasos y el médico que me puse ese
marcapasos
es un argentino y resulta que
él
me sorprendió porque hace sólo dos años
y medio que está acá en canadá y ya está
trabajando en el instituto de
cardiología de montreal por él
y le decía oye pero cómo es posible o
sea hay aquí hay una asociación de
médicos extranjeros que están luchando
para que se les acepte y para que puedan
practicar acá el tratado no el novio no
contratado el vino acá y bueno tenía
tenías y vino en un en un intercambio
pero la razón por la cual le pregunté
cómo es posible que ya tú estés acá de
trabajando y me decía que es la
universidad los estudios he hecho lo que
tú decías en medicina en argentina son
reconocidos por canadá mientras que no
lo son los de muchísimos otros países
pero no sé pues es una de las ventas
para añadir sobre la que no le quieres
saber qué es el canadá francés más que
el resto del canal y se viene de
tradiciones francesas y muy católicas y
es muy especial de cada este como ha
dicho de
de los medios públicos y también de todo
el mundo en las lo que mejoran es
increíble con million anillada de
dólares millones del ceas y en quebec
pero también en todas partes de canadá
donde hay franceses
hay una presencia francófona más
importante entonces de acuerdo muy bien
y sigamos con machi porque más chinos
nos mandó una foto
veámoslo a él entonces y es una foto de
cuando estaba trabajando con la agencia
france presse de noticias sus colegas de
allá y como aquí en mont a quien montará
también hacemos hasta aquí en radio
canadá también hacemos lo mismo ponernos
los suéteres vemos en navidad pero eso
no está feo tu suéter no está nada feo
[Risas]
estaba que en inglaterra es muy famoso
la tradición y luego en londres
pero además más que un ingrato al uso a
todo el mundo no solamente los empleados
los ejecutivos de empresas compiten para
ver qué sale con más frío
[Risas]
cuando le hace mucho bueno para empezar
este programa navideño les quería
presentar un vídeo pero nada más de
fondo para que vean es una es la primera
bailarina y él
de azúcar del cascanueces de los grand
valley canadiens de montreal que es una
de las instituciones de ballet más
importantes no la más importante porque
está en el ballet nacional de canadá que
es una institución importantísima
también pero el logran vale de montreal
son muy importantes y conversé con
vanesa garcía rival a montoya que es la
primera bailarina y ella es ella ahí la
vemos como el hada de azúcar entonces
nada más pues para darle un poco de tono
navideño al programa hay que decir que
el cascanueces vale de montreal no sé
cuántos años todos los que están
presentando ese espectáculo que de hecho
el fanta es fantástico y lo que es lindo
también es que es la misma coreografía
además desde hace aproximadamente
cuarenta y tantos años
y eso cambiarlos sólo cambian los que
interpretan claro pero es la misma
coreografía con la música de tchaikovsky
es hermoso es hermoso el cascanueces de
montreal bueno todos los cascarones yo
creo que es mágico en todos lados pero
bueno ahí nos cuenta vanesa garcía rival
a montoya en los desafíos que aún una
bailarina como ella sigue teniendo a
pesar de todos los años que llega que
lleva haciéndolo este clásico de navidad
nuestro español es de origen español
exactamente nació en españa vive aquí
desde hace muchos años también pero
bueno es una linda una linda
conversación con ella que nos cuenta
todo esto
exactamente y la vemos de nuevo y bueno
tenemos algunos mensajes en este caso
javier gonzález nunca le dice a la época
más bonita del año la navidad feliz y
fiestas para todos en radio canal
internacional
guil en abril dice hola feliz navidad y
próspero año nuevo para todo el equipo
de radio canal internacional
ismael zamora nos dice felices fiestas
felicidades para ustedes también
entonces ya qué
lado de la pantalla de las pantallas en
varias regiones de américa latina y de
canadá porque guild en abril donde vive
ross brawn work así que gracias a yle
nuevamente vamos a ver ahora si tienen
mensajes por ahí de otros responder a
otros comentarios de nuestros reportajes
si exactamente alguien tiene alguna
conexión en uno que manda laura acevedo
sobre el tema médico canadiense dice que
la diabetes tipo 2 es curable me dice
bueno me llamo laura qué increíble
artículo
realmente me pareció interesante la
información brindada además voy a
compartir este novedoso y único método
natural recientemente descubierto que me
ha ayudado mucho a controlar mi diabetes
y pasó a su aviso aquí no lo vamos a
difundir pero bueno hace referencia a
este artículo sobre la diabetes tipo 2
que tanto ha sido referenciado por
nuestro público en los últimos y las
últimas semanas
incluso meses casi años
yo aquí tengo un mensaje sobre
el artículo una pequeña ciudad
canadiense quiere acoger a gran número
de inmigrantes y gabriela espinoza nos
dice muy interesante pero hay un gran
problema y es que las empresas ni las
empresas nos conocen ni nosotros a ellas
y la comunicación es casi nula cómo
acceder a información de parte y parte
porque la mayoría de personas latinas y
no la tienes tenemos grandes capacidades
y no son aprovechadas
gabriela espinoza y nos hace siempre la
pregunta a nosotros que como podemos
hacer cómo puedo obtener esto y nosotros
no podemos hacer no no no sabemos cuáles
son todos los requisitos que se
necesitan para cada país en particular
yo por aquí tengo seis personas que
responden a un mensaje a una noticia que
hicimos canadá eligió 11 comunidades
rurales y del norte que acogerán
inmigrantes en el otoño del 2019 recién
entonces hay seis personas a víctor
manuel sánchez ruiz
johnny albino garcía
y yaron villegas silvestre marcos luis
eduardo ya sin faria maría de la torre
que nos preguntan información pero no
podemos no tenemos nosotros en forma de
una situación que vayan en su momento lo
dijimos con hicimos el salón de la
inmigración y nos retirábamos
posteriormente en la nota sobre el salón
de la inmigración que están los links a
cada una de las páginas de inmigración
de cada provincia y territorio
canadiense y saben federal puede ir
ahora de sacado final y en esas páginas
bien toda la información de todos los
programas y de todas las iniciativas
referidas inmigración erradicación
estatus permanente de residentes
etcétera etcétera quizás una fundamenta
y es parte del esfuerzo que ustedes allá
tienen que hacer para obtener esta
información nosotros no la tenemos acá
exactamente siempre les decimos también
que pueden referirse a las embajadas de
sus países a la embajada canadiense en
sus países de origen o los consulados
entonces siempre hay opciones dentro de
los países mismos para obtener esta
información más directamente yo tengo
aquí un mensaje sobre un reportaje
de género dice una mujer canadiense que
se encuentra en méxico quiere regresar a
su país con sus tres hijos que tienen
doble nacionalidad pero no cuenta con el
permiso del padre de sus hijos ya que
huye de casa por violencia familiar le
han dicho que es necesario ese permiso
para que entre a su propio país eso es
cierto que se puede hacer incluso tiene
familia en canadá dice sofía que no se
escribe desde no sabemos desde dónde
porque no nos especifica desde donde
pues yo creo sofía que lo mismo hay que
ir a las embajadas de canadá si esta
persona tiene nacionalidad o residencia
canadiense permanente tiene que
referirse al gobierno de canadá para
obtener información con respecto a este
caso hablan hizo la angr eso ya tiene lo
que no puedo hacer es viajar con los
menores de edad porque necesitan el
permiso paterno ahora en el caso
específico que esa consulta hay abogados
especializados en temas migratorios que
te van a poder dar una respuesta mucho
más asertiva que la nuestra están a
internet ahí en internet pues haciendo
un esfuerzo se busca la información y la
pueden obtener pero yo sé que canadá
iniciativas por eso digo que se refieren
también a las embajadas porque canadá
tiene iniciativas de protección a las
mujeres que sufren y que huyen de la
violencia de género entonces de la
violencia conyugal particularmente
cuando hay menores de peritación muy
particular y ahí tiene que haber una
autorización o decisión judicial que
permita viajar con los menores
exactamente qué les parece que vemos
nuestro vídeo de la aplicación
para que la gente pueda ir a bajar la
aplicación y tenerla directamente en su
sitio internet verdad leonardo así es y
ustedes pueden ir a las dos tiendas la
tienda de apple y la tienda de android
para bajar nuestra aplicación en
realidad la aplicación de radio canal
internacional se encuentra a cinco
idiomas en los cinco idiomas de
producción de nuestra casa de radio
qhana internacional les recomendamos que
baje el español si usted quiere bajar la
china baje la pero es la posición
absoluta allá ellos
el tema es que desde el español usted
puede ir a visitar también como se ve
arriba a la derecha tiene la entrada a
las informaciones más importantes de las
lenguas oficiales y después puede
también ir a ver otras de las lenguas
que ofrece radio internacional pero
básicamente es invitarlos a que vayan a
estas dos tiendas y pongan rs y en
español y encuentra la aplicación la
bajan mucho más ágil mucho más fiable y
está todo hasta nuestro programa lo
pueden ver gracias a la aplicación
muchas gracias leonardo vamos a hablar
ahora de los reportajes que hemos
preparado durante la semana que queremos
que la gente los vaya a visitar porque
están sí o no relacionados con navidad
no importa pero que los de modelos que
hemos trabajado esta semana y les pido
que lo hagan más o menos rapidito porque
tenemos música y un videíto con el que
quiero terminar el programa que es el
último del año así que luís bueno el
otro día vi una información que hablaba
de que había bajado la venta de autos
eléctricos en en ontario en la provincia
de ontario recurrí a la fuente de esa
información y real como decimos siempre
la información puede presentarse de
distintas maneras y si bien es cierto
que la venta de autos eléctricos bajó en
la provincia de ontario lo que la
información central decía es que en
canadá la venta de autos eléctricos
sigue creciendo sigue en aumento va en
aumento lentamente pero va en aumento en
el último año se vendieron en el país 16
mil 91 unidades eléctricas automóviles
eléctricos y lo que ocurrió en ontario
es que el gobierno de esa provincia ha
retirado
iniciativas que había para alentar la
venta de este tipo de vehículos y
entonces claro la gente entre los costos
que tienen nuestros autos porque cuestan
entre 10.000 y 30.000 dólares más que un
auto convencional según el modelo que
uno elija la gente a
ha optado por seguir comprando autos
convencionales en ontario pero en el
resto del país sigue subiendo la venta
de autos eléctricos hay diversas
iniciativas que impulsan la compra de
este tipo de vehículos en la mayoría de
las provincias y el futuro promisorio
para este sector tomando en cuenta
además la necesidad de ayudar a detener
de alguna manera el cambio climático eso
lo que queda nadie de tu reportaje que
en finlandia esta semana en un estudio
sobre los coches electrónicos eléctricas
eléctricos y dicen que es más probable
de tener un coche eléctrico eléctrico
que un coche normal con servir el micro
sobre apoyo lingüístico lanardo si nos
hablas no de casas inteligentes pero de
una cosa bien particular inteligente en
realidad salió de la charla con elvis la
semana pasada que me envió un link sobre
un caso muy particular que pasó en
misisipí donde
entraron en una niña de 8 años de edad
vivió una cosa espantosa tenía en su
casa instalada a su familia un amazon
print que es el dispositivo que uno pone
en la casa para cuando toca el timbre
ver quién es esa distancia y lo puede
tener un también en ese formato dentro
de la casa en este caso la niña fue
contactada por alguien de afuera alguien
empezó a hablar sí escuché ya vale en él
empezó a hablar y la invención insultar
y le empezó a decir cosas racistas y
diciéndole que tiene que portarse mal
todo esto en la habitación de la
criatura
o sea que evidentemente el riesgo fue
grande porque le estaban mirando desde
afuera a alguien que no saben quién
entonces hicieron la queja amazon y
trabajo una una actualización para darle
más seguridad las cámaras y por supuesto
insisten en que hay que tener la
verificación en dos pasos para lograr
que una capa más de seguridad para que
estas cosas no pasen y también
en realidad el aparato de seguro el
problema es que los cargas que se
utilizan otros elementos y uno está
acostumbrado a usar la misma el mismo
usuario y la misma contraseña para todas
las cuentas entonces uno puede entrar en
cualquier dispositivo de la casa
entonces si están pensando comprar eso
para navidad con mucho cuidado
-pablo tú nos hablas esta semana de cómo
reducir nuestra huella de carbono exacto
ya que estamos en navidad porque el
tenemos es el mes de las fiestas un mes
muy festivo y está el centro
internacional de rebelde referencias
sobre el ciclo de vida de los productos
que estudió la huella de carbono que
deja una familia tipo de cuatro personas
aquí en canadá durante este periodo
navideño y hacen el análisis de los
distintos
de las distintas etapas por las que
pasamos todos el que es que es la
navidad en la navidad pues es el
arbolito de navidad es la cena son los
viajes y es el paseo de sancha entonces
ellos calcularon la huella de carbono
que deja una familia tipo y si se debe
comprar un arbolito navideño de verdad o
un arbolito navideño oficial entonces
todo se hace todo este análisis y el
resultado es que una familia tipo de
días el resultado a la gente no va a ir
a ver tu reporte no sé pero ya son 268
kilos de gas carbónico canarias no sí
que una familia tipo deja como huella de
carbono
sí no
de vacaciones en cualquier lugar del
caribe porque si agarras el avión son
202 toneladas el desplazamiento de gas
carbónico por el simple hecho de agarrar
y viajar en avión entonces pues son 67
kilos por persona que deja los
canadienses como huella de carbono si yo
les doy justamente algunos consejos para
explicarles a los niños que no se puede
o no se quiere comprar todo lo que
escribieron en su lista de pedido de
regalos hay que explicarles a los niños
por qué no se puede y por qué no se
quiere justamente hablamos del consumo
excesivo
bueno el organismo hábil o medias o
medias smart es de aquí de canadá da
varios consejos de cómo explicar a los
niños porque en realidad es una cuestión
de hablar con ellos y mostrarle la
realidad de la navidad a los niños
hablarles de basura hablar desde huella
ecológica y otras razones de financieras
también entonces yo los invito a que
escuchen este reportaje y que lo vean
también
información y algunos consejos muy
prácticos para esta navidad
entonces ya se nos ha puesto esta foto
de la niña
[Risas]
así que si vale la pena que vayan a ver
vamos a ver no se va a acercar a por un
momento el ratito bueno lo vamos a dejar
con un poco de música el isap y aisha
que probablemente la recuerdan es un
artista y nunca del ártico canadiense y
ella hizo una versión en in actitud la
lengua la lengua de los inuit justamente
de noche de paz entonces ahí se la pueda
la podemos ver un poquito y mientras
leonardo tiene unos mensajes y un último
mensaje gustavo lucas dice cuando cursé
años en la universidad de la carrera de
relaciones internacionales tuvo
compañeras del curso de carrera y habían
venido de noruega dicen uruguay también
la cultura
es gratuita en general
muchas gracias a gustavo lucas y
escuchamos entonces a elisa ping
no sé si alguno de ustedes tiene algún
mensaje navideño no yo me quedé pensando
el último que decíamos sobre la impronta
la huella que uno deja de navidad y
cuando lo hice lo que vos decías de los
padres que tienen que explicarle los
hijos porque no se puede comprar todo lo
que ellos tienen pero navidad si son los
mismos padres que le venden los hijos de
papá noel hay una contradicción ya de
base habría que empezar por eso pero yo
creo que hay hay maneras de explicarles
a los niños y guardar la magia de papá
noel y no necesariamente comprar a los
niños hay que decir la verdad
y también la magia de navidad es
importantísima también sin embargo hay
otras cosas hay otros gestos no el
cierto por ejemplo
y recibir regalos y regalar lo que no
usa más entonces para volver al vídeo es
interesante de saber que ella está lista
para revisar y está cantando en actitud
y a ella le gusta mucho cantar en
actitud y esta canción especialmente
porque las sonoridades de la lengua son
diferentes de nuestras tías y que es
guapísimo para oírlo
aisha que entonces y los voy a dejar con
otro vídeo porque ya no vamos y tenemos
que ir viendo al papá noel justamente
luis no le va a gustar el papá noel pero
yo tengo un gol y lo sacaron voy a
entregar los regalos o no así que no
tiene ningún regalo así que a lo mejor
lo busca
que pasen unas lindas fiestas y próspero
año 2020
[Música]
bien